So, here's how a lawyer meets with his client when his client is a prisoner at Guantanamo. There's a little hut with a metal table.
所以，这就是律师在关塔那摩会见作为囚犯的当事人时的情景。那是一个带金属桌子的小棚子。
He's brought out of the box and shackled to an eye bolt in the floor with his back to the door. He's forbidden to face the natural light.
他被带出禁闭室，背对门口被锁在地板上的吊环螺栓上。他不被允许面对自然光。
Joe Margulies of the University of Chicago represents a few detainees at Guantanamo, and he says that to understand that thing about the natural light, you have to understand that the detention facilities at Guantanamo were designed to be the perfect interrogation chambers. And so anything the prisoner wants, including sunlight, he's only going to get with the permission of his interrogators as a reward for cooperating. And anything can be used that way.
芝加哥大学的乔·马古利斯代表了关塔那摩的几名被拘留者，他说，要理解关于自然光的那件事，你必须明白，关塔那摩的拘留设施被设计成完美的审讯室。因此，囚犯想要的任何东西，包括阳光，他只有在审问者允许的情况下，作为配合的奖励才能得到。任何东西都可以以这种方式被利用。
Mail. Another lawyer discovered when he first got there that his client, a middle-aged gentlemen with five children. He's a London businessman who was picked up in the Gambia, and he wasn't getting any mail from his family, and he couldn't understand it because he felt abandoned and alone from his five children. And the lawyer had the presence of mind to make inquiries to see what was the matter and discovered that 16 letters were in the military's possession that they had refused to deliver. And when they did finally deliver them, someone had actually taken the time to redact out the words from the children, we miss you daddy, we love you daddy, we're thinking of you. That is apparently not right because it disrupts the sense of isolation and despair that they are trying to cultivate.
信件。另一位律师在第一次到那里时发现，他的当事人是一位有五个孩子的中年绅士。他是一位在冈比亚被抓的伦敦商人，他收不到家人的任何信件，他无法理解，因为他感到被五个孩子抛弃和孤立。律师有先见之明，去询问情况，发现军方手里有16封信，他们拒绝投递。当他们最终投递这些信时，有人竟然花时间把孩子们写的话涂掉了，比如“爸爸我们想你”、“爸爸我们爱你”、“我们在想你”。这显然是不对的，因为它破坏了他们试图营造的孤立和绝望感。
If prisoners feel despair, they'll cooperate, they'll talk. They'll tell us all the dangerous things they know. That's the idea. Let's make them feel hopeless.
如果囚犯感到绝望，他们就会配合，他们就会开口。他们会告诉我们他们所知道的所有危险事情。这就是意图。让我们让他们感到绝望。
Ever since President Bush announced the global war on terror, we've been told this is a different kind of war with different rules. The battlefield isn't a jungle in Asia or a beach in France, it's everywhere. Soldiers aren't guys in uniform, they could be anybody. And prisoners of war are different too. So dangerous, we're told, that we keep them in an offshore facility and as close to total secrecy as possible. To interrogate whenever we want, however long we want, using methods we have never approved for other wars.
自从布什总统宣布全球反恐战争以来，我们一直被告知这是一场规则不同的战争。战场不是亚洲的丛林或法国的海滩，而是无处不在。士兵不是穿制服的人，他们可能是任何人。战俘也不同。我们被告知，他们太危险了，所以我们将他们关押在离岸设施中，尽可能保持完全保密。想审就审，想审多久就审多久，使用我们在其他战争中从未批准过的方法。
And one thing that's just weird about Guantanamo is that in all of these years that it's been going, why haven't we seen more of these guys on radio and TV? Roughly 400 of them have been released. About a year ago on our radio show we were talking about this and we realized that none of us had ever read or heard any interview with any of them. And so we decided that we were going to try to get some of these guys onto the air. And the show that we put together and put on the air a year ago with those interviews just won a big award, the Peabody Award. And so because of that, we bring you that show again today. Updated here and there where the facts have changed a little bit.
关于关塔那摩有一件很奇怪的事，那就是这么多年来，为什么我们没能在广播和电视上看到更多这些人？大约有400人被释放。大约一年前，在我们的广播节目中，我们谈到了这一点，我们意识到我们中没有人读过或听过任何对他们的采访。于是我们决定，我们要试着让这些人中的一些人上节目。我们在一年多前制作并播出的那些采访节目刚刚赢得了皮博迪奖。因此，今天我们再次为您带来那个节目。事实有所变化的地方已进行了更新。
And so today you're going to hear from two of these Guantanamo detainees who have been released. And I believe you're going to be very surprised at what they're like. We're also going to try to explain, once and for all, what all of these kind of technical sounding things about hearings and raids and new rules of war that we all hear in the news from time to time, what it all adds up to. It's This American Life from Chicago Public Radio, distributed by Public Radio International, I'm Ira Glass.
今天你们将听到两位被释放的关塔那摩被拘留者的讲述。我相信你们会对他们是什么样的人感到非常惊讶。我们还将试着一劳永逸地解释，我们在新闻中不时听到的关于听证会、突袭和新的战争规则等这些听起来很专业的东西到底意味着什么。这是来自芝加哥公共广播电台的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Our guide for all of this is Jack Hitt. Here he is.
我们的向导是杰克·希特。他来了。
As best as they can tell, Badr Zaman Badr and his brother were imprisoned in Guantanamo for three years for telling a joke. Actually, for telling two jokes. They ran a satire magazine in Pakistan that poked fun at corrupt clerics, sort of the Pashto edition of The Onion.
据他们所知，巴德·扎曼·巴德和他的兄弟在关塔那摩被关了三年，原因仅仅是讲了一个笑话。实际上，是讲了两个笑话。他们在巴基斯坦经营一本讽刺杂志，嘲弄腐败的教士，类似于普什图语版的《洋葱报》。
The first joke that got them into trouble was when they published a poem about a politician called, "I am Glad to be a Leader." Here's Badr.
让他们惹上麻烦的第一个笑话是他们发表了一首关于一位政客的诗，题目是《我很高兴成为领导人》。这是巴德。
Let me translate a few lines for you.
让我为你翻译几行。
Sure.
当然。
Before I was so thin and weak and now I have big stomach. Stuff like that, yeah.
以前我既瘦又弱，现在我有了大肚子。诸如此类，是的。
So the guy with the big stomach called about Badr and his brother. He threatened them. And as best as they can tell, told authorities that they were linked to al-Qaeda, which landed them in Guantanamo, and which leads us to the second joke.
所以那个大肚子的家伙告发了巴德和他的兄弟。他威胁了他们。据他们所知，他告诉当局他们与基地组织有联系，这把他们送进了关塔那摩，这也引出了第二个笑话。
This one was in an issue of Badr's magazine that came out in the '90s, after our government set a $5 million reward for Osama bin Laden. Badr's magazine issued its own bounty for the capture of an American leader.
这个笑话出现在巴德杂志90年代的一期中，就在我们政府为奥萨马·本·拉登悬赏500万美元之后。巴德的杂志为抓捕一位美国领导人发布了他们自己的悬赏。
President Bill Clinton. Giving the details how to identify that he has blue eyes and he's clean-shaven. And the most important thing is that there is some scandal going on between Clinton and Monica Lewinsky. If someone finds that man, he will be rewarded $5 million of money. Of [UNINTELLIGIBLE] currency, which was equal to $113 at that time. So it's impossible to [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
比尔·克林顿总统。详细说明了如何辨认他有蓝眼睛，而且刮得干干净净。最重要的是克林顿和莫妮卡·莱温斯基之间发生的丑闻。如果有人找到那个人，他将获得500万美元的奖励。以当时的货币计算，相当于113美元。所以这是不可能的。
In Guantanamo, were you interrogated about your Clinton satire?
在关塔那摩，你是否因为你的克林顿讽刺文章而受到审讯？
Exactly. They would see if we really to want to kill President Clinton. And we said, no, that was only a satire and it's only a way of expression. It's allowed. It's protected in your country, in American law.
正是如此。他们想看看我们是否真的想杀掉克林顿总统。我们说，不，那只是讽刺，这只是一种表达方式。这是允许的。在你们的国家，在美国法律中，这是受保护的。
How many times were you interrogated you think about the Clinton article?
你认为你因为那篇克林顿文章被审讯了多少次？
Many times. Many times. Me and my brother, each one of us have been interrogated more than 150 times.
很多次。很多次。我和我兄弟，我们每个人都被审讯了150多次。
So after hearing the punchline explained a 150 times, we finally get the joke, and sent Badr and his brother home. It had been three years since the Pakistani army surrounded their house in Peshawar, came into their living room, which is lined with wall to wall bookcases and arrested them. That's Badr's version of why we jailed him. Here's President Bush's.
所以在听了150次笑话的梗后，我们终于听懂了这个笑话，把巴德和他的兄弟送回了家。巴基斯坦军队包围他们在白沙瓦的房子，闯入他们摆满书架的客厅并将他们逮捕，那已经是三年前的事了。那是巴德认为我们关押他的版本。这是布什总统的版本。
These are people that got scooped up off a battlefield attempting to kill US troops. I want to make sure before they're released that they don't come back to kill again.
这些人是在战场上被抓获并试图杀害美军的人。在他们被释放之前，我想确保他们不会回来再次杀人。
The administration has never wavered on this point. Here's Dick Cheney on Guantanamo.
政府在这个问题上从未动摇过。这是迪克·切尼关于关塔那摩的说法。
The people that are there are people we picked up on the battlefield, primarily in Afghanistan. They're terrorists. They're bomb makers. They're facilitators of terror. They're members of al-Qaeda and the Taliban.
那里的人是我们主要在阿富汗战场上抓获的人。他们是恐怖分子。他们是炸弹制造者。他们是恐怖主义的推动者。他们是基地组织和塔利班的成员。
We're told over and over that these prisoners are so terrible that we need an offshore facility away from US law to hold them. But then there's Badr. And every day, more stories like his are coming out. And they raise the question, is Guantanamo a camp full of terrorists, or a camp full of mistakes?
我们被反复告知，这些囚犯太可怕了，我们需要一个远离美国法律的离岸设施来关押他们。但后来有了巴德。每天都有更多像他这样的故事传出。它们提出了一个问题：关塔那摩是充满恐怖分子的营地，还是充满错误的营地？
In a new study from Seton Hall's law school, researcher simply went to the trouble of reading the 517 Guantanamo case files released by the Pentagon. Here's what they found.
在西顿霍尔法学院的一项新研究中，研究人员只是费心阅读了五角大楼发布的517份关塔那摩案件档案。这就是他们的发现。
Only 5% of our detainees in Guantanamo were scooped up by American troops on the battlefield, or anywhere else. 5%. The rest, we never saw them fighting.
我们关塔那摩的被拘留者中只有5%是被美军在战场或其他任何地方抓获的。5%。其余的，我们从未见过他们战斗。
And here's something else. Only 8% of the detainees in Guantanamo are classified by the Pentagon as al-Qaeda fighters. In fact, Michael Dunleavy, head of interrogations at Guantanamo, complained in 2002 that he was receiving too many quote, "Mickey Mouse prisoners."
还有一件事。关塔那摩的被拘留者中只有8%被五角大楼归类为基地组织战士。事实上，关塔那摩审讯负责人迈克尔·邓利维在2002年抱怨说，他收到了太多的所谓“米老鼠囚犯”。
In 2004, the New York Times did a huge investigation, interviewing dozens of high-level military intelligence and law enforcement officials in the US, Europe, and the Middle East. There was a surprising consensus. That out of nearly 600 men at Guantanamo, the number who could give us useful information about al-Qaeda, was quote, "only a relative handful." Some put the number at about a dozen, others more than two dozen.
2004年，《纽约时报》进行了大规模调查，采访了美国、欧洲和中东的数十名高层军事情报和执法官员。出现了一个令人惊讶的共识：在关塔那摩近600人中，能够提供有关基地组织有用信息的人数，“只是相对少数”。有些人估计约为十几人，另一些人则估计有二十多人。
The Seton Hall study might help explain that. It revealed that 86% of the detainees were handed over to us by Pakistan or the Northern Alliance. And some were handed over to us by a new method. Here's Badr.
西顿霍尔的研究或许有助于解释这一点。它揭示了86%的被拘留者是由巴基斯坦或北方联盟移交给我们的。有些人是通过一种新方法交给我们的。这是巴德。
Actually, in our interrogation, the American interrogators have been telling us that they have paid a lot of money to those who handed over us to American.
事实上，在审讯中，美国审讯者一直告诉我们，他们支付了大量金钱给那些把我们交给美国的人。
The problem was, we were offering bounties. You know, $5,000 or $10,000. Al-Qaeda brought more than Taliban did and, so OK, fine, here's your money. Take them to Gitmo. That's where Admiral John Hutson, the Navy's top lawyer. He was the judge advocate general until 2000. He says, essentially, we bought Badr and a whole lot of other prisoners.
问题是，我们提供了悬赏。你知道，5000美元或1万美元。基地组织带来的比塔利班多，所以好的，没问题，这是你的钱。把他们带到关塔那摩。那是海军最高律师约翰·赫特上将说的话。他在2000年之前一直是海军军法署署长。他基本上说，我们购买了巴德和许多其他囚犯。
When you look at the economy at that part of the world, that really is kind of a king's ransom.
当你看看世界那个地方的经济时，这确实算是巨额赎金。
When the Pentagon started offering these rewards, large fees for top leaders, like Bin laden, and smaller payouts for lower level terrorists and Taliban, it seemed like a good idea. They didn't think it would lead to innocent people being turned in. Here's defense secretary Donald Rumsfeld in 2001, just two months after September 11.
当五角大楼开始提供这些奖励时，为像本·拉登这样的高级领导人提供巨额报酬，为低级别的恐怖分子和塔利班提供较小的报酬，这看起来是个好主意。他们没想过这会导致无辜的人被上交。这是国防部长唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德在2001年，即9/11事件发生仅两个月后的讲话。
We have large rewards out. And our hope is that the incentive through the great principle of University of Chicago economics incentivize a large number of people to begin crawling through those tunnels and caves looking for the bad folks.
我们发布了巨额悬赏。我们的希望是通过芝加哥大学经济学的伟大原则，激励大量人开始穿过那些隧道和洞穴寻找坏人。
We all know this is a new war with new rules, but what were the old rules? Well, one had to do with POWs. The military has always known that all kinds of prisoners get picked up in the fog of war, so it was important to get those numbers down to just the real POWs since troops on the move didn't want to be burdened with looking after lots and lots of captives. This problem had been more or less solved by the old Geneva Conventions, which required a quote, "competent tribunal." It sounds crazy, a kind of impromptu court hearing, right after a battle. But that is exactly what used to happen. And typically, some 75% to 90% of the people scooped up would be sent home.
我们都知道这是一场规则不同的新战争，但旧规则是什么？好吧，其中一条与战俘有关。军方一直知道，在战争的迷雾中，各种各样的囚犯都会被抓获，所以重要的是将这些数字减少到真正的战俘，因为移动的部队不想负担看管大量的俘虏。这个问题通过旧的《日内瓦公约》或多或少得到了解决，该公约要求一个所谓的“主管法庭”。听起来很疯狂，一种即兴的法庭听证会，就在战斗之后。但这正是过去发生的事情。通常，被抓获的75%到90%的人会被送回家。
In the Gulf War of 1991, we captured 982 people, released 750 of them right away, and the remainder were POWs. Like in the old war movies, they give name, rank, and serial number, and they got certain things. Everything from a pledge that they wouldn't be tortured, to a promise that they would be released once the war ended, and even the right to send letters home. Here's rear admiral Hutson, the navy's top lawyer.
在1991年的海湾战争中，我们俘虏了982人，立即释放了750人，其余的是战俘。就像老战争电影里一样，他们报上姓名、军衔和序列号，他们得到某些东西。从承诺他们不会被折磨，到承诺战争结束后释放他们，甚至还有写信回家的权利。这是海军最高律师赫特海军少将。
And those were some of the things that now Attorney General Gonzales referred to as being quaint and outdated. You get athletic uniforms. You get a certain amount of money paid in Swiss francs, I believe. And those things probably are--
这些就是现在的总检察长冈萨雷斯所指的古怪和过时的东西。你得到运动服。你得到一定数量的钱，我想是用瑞士法郎支付的。那些事情可能——
You get paid as a POW?
你作为战俘还能领钱？
Yeah, it's a very small amount of money, but to go to the commissary and buy chewing gum and cigarettes kind of thing. And those things probably are largely outdated. And they are in some respects, quaint. What happened though, is by saying that the Geneva Conventions in those respects were quaint and outdated, they just threw the baby out with the bath water.
是的，数额非常少，但是可以去小卖部买口香糖和香烟之类的东西。那些事情可能在很大程度上已经过时了。在某些方面，它们确实很古怪。然而，发生的情况是，通过说日内瓦公约在这些方面是古怪和过时的，他们简直是把婴儿和洗澡水一起倒掉了。
This is a new kind of war after all, and the administration made the argument that the Geneva Conventions apply only when you're fighting another country, a country with a uniformed army, not when you're fighting terrorists.
毕竟，这是一场新型的战争，政府辩称《日内瓦公约》只有在你与另一个国家战斗时才适用，一个有正规军的国家，而不是当你与恐怖分子战斗时。
They do not apply where the individuals captured haven't deserved, haven't shown that they deserve those protections.
它们不适用于那些被俘个人还不配、还没有表现出他们值得那些保护的情况。
That's Brian Boyle. He was associate attorney general for President Bush when these decisions were made.
那是布莱恩·博伊尔。当这些决定做出时，他是布什总统的副司法部长。
They did not legally qualify as prisoners of war because they are not fighting in uniform. Because they try to blend in with the civilian population. Because they try to take cover in civilian areas.
他们在法律上没有资格作为战俘，因为他们没有穿制服战斗。因为他们试图混入平民中。因为他们试图躲在民用区域。
Hasn't that been a problem for war for most of the 20th century, or at least, in the last couple of conflicts we've been in? I mean, is rooting out al-Qaeda any harder, or how is it harder than rooting out Viet Cong in a local village?
在20世纪的大部分时间里，或者至少在我们参与的最后几次冲突中，这不是战争的一个问题吗？我的意思是，根除基地组织比根除当地村庄里的越共更难吗，或者它怎么就更难了？
And I take the point. I guess the point I was making earlier is that I don't think you can conclude given the nature of the enemy we're facing that how we treat al-Qaeda operatives that we're able to capture is going to make any difference at all in how they would treat American personnel in their custody. It wouldn't make a difference at all.
我明白这一点。我想我之前表达的观点是，我不认为考虑到我们面对的敌人的性质，我们可以断定我们如何对待我们能够抓获的基地组织人员会改变他们对待被俘美国人员的方式。这根本不会有任何区别。
That argument can really take you to some dark places, I think.
我认为，这种论点真的会把你带向一些黑暗的地方。
Here's rear admiral Hutson.
这是赫特海军少将。
If we pick and choose, then other countries can pick and choose whether they're going to apply the Geneva Conventions. That is a slippery slope that Secretary Powell and others did not want us to go down. Because they're looking over the horizon. They know that this isn't the last war we're going to fight. It's not even the next the last war we're going to fight.
如果我们挑肥拣瘦，那么其他国家也可以挑选他们是否要应用《日内瓦公约》。这是一条滑坡，鲍威尔国务卿和其他人不想让我们走下去。因为他们正在展望未来。他们知道这不是我们将要打的最后一场战争。甚至不是倒数第二场战争。
This quarrel about the Geneva Conventions continued for three years and eventually, got down to one, very practical question. If you're a prisoner and you're not protected by the Geneva Conventions, and you might be held indefinitely, could you at least make an appeal in a US court? Here's attorney general Alberto Gonzales.
这场关于《日内瓦公约》的争吵持续了三年，最终归结为一个非常实际的问题。如果你是一名囚犯，不受《日内瓦公约》保护，并且可能被无限期关押，你至少可以在美国法院上诉吗？这是总检察长阿尔贝托·冈萨雷斯。
We really are, for all intents and purposes, at war. And so you need not provide access to counsel. You need not provide the ability to challenge their detention in a criminal court. It would be like saying that Germans that were captured during World War II would have to provided lawyers. The truth of the matter is, the rules and procedures of our criminal justice system simply do not apply in this case.
我们确实在所有意图和目的上处于战争状态。所以你不需要提供律师。你不需要提供在刑事法庭上质疑他们拘留的能力。这就好比说在二战中被俘的德国人必须提供律师。事实是，我们刑事司法系统的规则和程序在这种情况中根本不适用。
And he's absolutely right, about the Germans. Except the Germans were covered by the Geneva Conventions.
他说得完全对，关于德国人。除了德国人受《日内瓦公约》保护。
Finally, in 2004, the United States Supreme Court stepped in. It said, if prisoners aren't going to be covered by the Geneva Conventions, that's fine. But they couldn't be permitted to fall into a legal black hole, not protected by any law at all. They had to be given some way to challenge their detainment. It's one of the oldest rights in Western civilization, known as habeas corpus.
最终，在2004年，美国最高法院介入了。它说，如果囚犯不受《日内瓦公约》保护，那没问题。但不能允许他们陷入一个不受任何法律保护的法律黑洞。必须给他们某种方式来质疑他们的拘留。这是西方文明中最古老的权利之一，被称为人身保护令。
Habeas corpus, it's a phrase we all know, but let's be honest, can't ever really remember what it means. It's not a trial or anything like one. It's more, well, primal. It's a hearing that commands the executive-- in this case, the president-- to explain why he has jailed somebody. The idea dates back to 1215 England when the nobles forced King John to sign the Magna Carta and agree to the great writ, later known as habeas corpus.
人身保护令，这是一个我们都知道的短语，但老实说，从没真正记住它意味着什么。它不是审判或类似审判的东西。它更，嗯，原始。这是一个命令行政部门——在本案中是总统——解释他为什么关押某人的听证会。这个想法可以追溯到1215年的英格兰，当时贵族们强迫约翰王签署《大宪章》并同意大令状，后来被称为人身保护令。
In Latin, it means, "show me the body." In other words, a neutral judge got to see the prisoner in person to check if he'd been tortured, and then the judge had the power to require the king to explain, why is this guy jailed? All the executive had to do was answer with a convincing story, and then the guy went back to the dungeon. It's a right so elemental that it's in Article 1 of the United States Constitution. It's one of the reasons we fought the Revolutionary War.
在拉丁语中，它意味着“让我看看尸体”。换句话说，一位公正的法官必须亲自见到囚犯以检查他是否受到折磨，然后法官有权要求国王解释，为什么这个人被关押？行政部门所要做的只是用一个令人信服的故事来回答，然后那个人就回到了地牢。这是一项如此基础的权利，以至于它出现在美国宪法第1条中。这就是我们打革命战争的原因之一。
And after the Supreme Court granted the detainees access to the courts, right away President Bush started talking like a habeas loving King John.
在最高法院授予被拘留者进入法院的权利后，布什总统立刻开始表现得像一位热爱人身保护令的约翰王。
Yeah, look, we are a nation of laws and to the extent that people say, well, America is no longer a nation of laws, that does hurt our reputation. But I think it's an unfair criticism. As you might remember, our courts have made a ruling. They looked at the jurisdiction, the right of people in Guantanamo to have habeas review, and so we're now complying with the court's decisions.
是啊，看，我们是一个法治国家，如果人们说，嗯，美国不再是一个法治国家，那确实损害了我们的声誉。但我认为这是一个不公平的批评。正如你可能记得的那样，我们的法院做出了裁决。他们审视了管辖权，即关塔那摩的人拥有人身保护令审查的权利，所以我们现在正在遵守法院的决定。
The administration quickly put together a kind of hearing based in part on the old Geneva Conventions hearing they'd abandoned. They called this hearing, a combatant status review tribunal, or in the elegant shorthand of the Pentagon, a CSRT.
政府很快组织了一种听证会，部分基于他们放弃的旧《日内瓦公约》听证会。他们称这次听证会为战斗人员身份审查法庭，或者用五角大楼优雅的缩写，CSRT。
These new hearings have one oddity to them. The tribunal assumes all the evidence against the detainee is correct. If the detainee wants to prove them wrong, it will be difficult because he's not allowed to see the evidence. It's classified. As a result, these hearings makes strange reading. In many of them, there comes a moment in the dialogue like this one between detainee Abdulmalik and the judging panel. Malik--
这些新的听证会有一个奇怪之处。法庭假设对被拘留者不利的所有证据都是正确的。如果被拘留者想证明他们错了，那将很困难，因为他不被允许查看这些证据。它是机密的。结果，这些听证会的记录读起来很奇怪。在其中许多听证会中，对话中会出现像被拘留者阿卜杜勒马利克和法官小组之间这样的时刻。马利克——
Regarding the charge that I worked at various guest houses and offices, what was the work?
关于我曾在各种宾馆和办公室工作的指控，那是些什么工作？
JUDGE: I cannot answer that. This is the first time we've seen the evidence. I know nothing more than what is written here.
法官：我无法回答。这是我们第一次看到这些证据。除了写在这里的东西，我一无所知。
MALIK: Same with me. I don't know anything about this. Regarding the charge that I was frequently seen at Osama bin Laden's side, who saw me?
马利克：我也一样。对此我一无所知。关于我经常在奥萨马·本·拉登身边被看到的指控，是谁看到了我？
JUDGE: I don't know.
法官：我不知道。
MALIK: If it says was frequently seen, you have to prove that.
马利克：如果上面写着经常被看到，你必须证明这一点。
The Supreme Court had said that the detainees didn't deserve a full criminal trial, of course. Only the basics of a fair hearing, which came down to three things. A lawyer, an impartial judge, and the chance to see the evidence against them. In practice though, they get none of these.
最高法院当然已经表示，被拘留者不配进行全面的刑事审判。只有公平听证会的基本要求，这归结为三点：律师、公正的法官，以及查看针对他们的证据的机会。但在实践中，他们一个也没有。
Baher Azmy is a lawyer who represents one of the detainees, but he couldn't attend his client's CSRT because actual lawyers aren't allowed.
巴赫·阿兹米是一名代表其中一名被拘留者的律师，但他无法参加他当事人的CSRT，因为真正的律师不被允许参加。
They were each appointed a personal representative who's a military officer. Who, in my case, met with my client the day before for 15 minutes, sat silent, and failed to present all of the exculpatory evidence in his file. Which of course, any lawyer would have done. Not the personal representative.
他们每个人都被指派了一名个人代表，即一名军官。在我的案子中，他在前一天和我当事人见了15分钟，保持沉默，并且未能提交他档案中所有的无罪证据。当然，任何律师都会这样做。而不是那个个人代表。
And as for confronting the evidence, consider the case of Azmy's client, Murat Kurnaz, a Turkish citizen raised in Germany. The Pentagon accidentally declassified the file with all of the secret evidence against him. And here's what's in it: nothing.
至于面对证据，考虑一下阿兹米的当事人穆拉特·库尔纳兹的案子，他是一名在德国长大的土耳其公民。五角大楼意外解密了所有针对他的秘密证据档案。以下是里面的内容：什么都没有。
The classified files contains-- the Washington Post wrote about it-- six statements from military intelligence. That's really what the classified file is, memos saying this person was here, so and so witnessed him. In Kurnaz's case, there are five or six statements saying, there's no evidence of any connection to al-Qaeda, the Taliban, or threat to the United States. The Germans have concluded he's got no connection to al-Qaeda. There's no evidence linking him to the Taliban, over and over and over again.
机密档案包含——《华盛顿邮报》对此进行了报道——来自军事情报局的六份声明。机密档案实际上就是这样，备忘录说这个人曾在某地，某人目击了他。在库尔纳兹的案子中，有五六份声明说，没有证据表明他与基地组织、塔利班有任何联系，或对美国构成威胁。德国人得出的结论是他与基地组织没有联系。没有证据将他与塔利班联系起来，一遍又一遍。
But here's the thing, at the hearing, nobody talks about any of that. His personal representative doesn't bring it up. The tribunal doesn't consider it and Kurnaz, himself, doesn't even know about it. He's declared an enemy combatant and sent back to his cell.
但关键是，在听证会上，没有人谈论这些。他的个人代表没有提出来。法庭不考虑它，库尔纳兹本人甚至不知道这些。他被宣布为敌方战斗人员并送回了他的牢房。
But wait, there's more. The reason they give for holding him, a friend of his named [? Selcuk Bilgin ?] blew himself up as a suicide bomber in Turkey in 2003. That's two years after Kurnaz got picked up.
但是等等，还有更多。他们关押他的理由是，他的一个名叫赛尔库克·比尔金的朋友在2003年的土耳其自杀式爆炸中炸死了自己。那是库尔纳兹被抓获两年后。
So setting aside the sort of remarkable legal proposition that one could be detained indefinitely for what one's friend does, it's factually preposterous. And a sort of simple Google search or a call to the Germans would have revealed that his friend is alive and well in [UNINTELLIGIBLE] and under no suspicion of any such thing.
所以，撇开一个人可能因为朋友的行为而被无限期拘留这种惊人的法律主张不谈，这在事实上是荒谬的。只需进行简单的谷歌搜索或给德国人打个电话就会发现，他的朋友活得好好的，没有受到任何此类怀疑。
You heard that right. Kurnaz was held in Guantanamo because two years after he got picked up, some guy he knows became a suicide bomber. Except that he didn't become a suicide bomber and is currently living in Germany.
你没听错。库尔纳兹被关在关塔那摩，因为在他被抓获两年后，他认识的一个家伙成了自杀式炸弹袭击者。只是他并没有成为自杀式炸弹袭击者，目前正住在德国。
Yeah, he's walking around in Germany. I've met him.
是啊，他正在德国走动。我见过他。
Then there's a bunch of Chinese Muslims who we accidentally picked up during our sweep in Afghanistan. They're an ethnic minority known as the Uyghurs, and they've been battling the communist Chinese since World War II. Conservatives love the Uyghurs, which is why they've been passionately defended by the National Review and the Weekly Standard.
还有一群中国穆斯林，我们在阿富汗的扫荡中意外抓获了他们。他们是一个被称为维吾尔族的少数民族，从二战以来一直与中国共产党作战。保守派热爱维吾尔人，这就是为什么他们一直受到《国家评论》和《标准周刊》的热情捍卫。
After a corporate lawyer named Sabin Willett heard about them, he volunteered to represent a Uyghur named Adel Abdul Hakim and some others, and he flew to Guantanamo to meet them.
在一位名叫萨宾·威利特的商业律师听说他们之后，他自愿代表一名名叫阿德尔·阿卜杜勒·哈基姆和其他人，并飞往关塔那摩去见他们。
The main thing they wanted to talk about it and that was so puzzling to them was that the previous May, the military had told them that they were in their words, "innocent." And why were they still here if they were innocent?
他们想谈的主要事情，也是让他们感到困惑的是，前一年五月，军方用他们的话告诉他们，他们是“无辜的”。如果他们是无辜的，为什么他们还在这里？
What you're saying is, is that Adel and the other Uyghurs are, in your opinion, have never been members of any kind of al-Qaeda or Jihad, or anything like that?
你的意思是，在你看，阿德尔和其他维吾尔人从来都不是任何基地组织或圣战组织的一员，或者是类似的东西？
Yeah, it's not just my opinion. The Defense Department has determined that. That means they were never al-Qaeda, never Taliban, never any of that.
是的，这不仅仅是我的观点。国防部已经确定了这一点。这意味着他们从来都不是基地组织，从来都不是塔利班，从来都不是那些东西。
When I interviewed Willett, back when this story was first broadcast a year ago, the government said they'd release Adel and the other Uyghurs if only it could find another country to send them to. At the time, there seemed like an obvious solution. Adel could go 90 miles north to Miami, where there's an entire city of anti-communists. Or, he could be sent to one of the largest Uyghur ex-pat communities, Washington DC. So why didn't that happen? Here's Willett.
当我采访威利特时，在一年多前这个故事第一次播出时，政府说他们会释放阿德尔和其他维吾尔人，只要能找到另一个国家把他们送过去。当时，似乎有一个明显的解决方案。阿德尔可以向北走90英里去迈阿密，那里有一个完整的反共城市。或者，他可以被送到最大的维吾尔海外社区之一，华盛顿特区。那么为什么没发生呢？这是威利特。
I'll tell you what I think the answer is, although no one from the government would admit this. I think the answer is that if anybody actually met these guys, actually looked at them, and took their pictures, and had them on TV shows or the radio, they'd be shocked. Because they've been told for four years that the people at Guantanamo are terrorists and that they're the worst of the worst. And you take a look at Adel, you're going to suddenly realize you've been lied to for a long time.
我会告诉你我认为答案是什么，尽管政府里没有人会承认这一点。我认为答案是，如果有人真的见了这些人，真的看了看他们，并拍了他们的照片，让他们上了电视节目或广播，他们会感到震惊。因为四年来他们被告知关塔那摩的人是恐怖分子，他们是坏人中的坏人。如果你看看阿德尔，你会突然意识到你被骗了很长时间。
He struck me when I first him, like the kind of kid your college age son would bring home. You know, his roommate. His buddy from college home for the weekend. People who meet Adel for the first time, they walk out of the meeting and their jaw is a little bit unsprung, and they don't say much. Because it's hitting them like a ton of bricks. You know, this guy is in Guantanamo?
我第一次见到他时，他给我的印象就像你大学年龄的儿子会带回家的那种孩子。你知道，他的室友。从大学回家过周末的哥们。第一次见到阿德尔的人，他们走出会议室时下巴有点脱臼，他们说不出太多话。因为这像砖头一样重重地击中了他们。你知道，这家伙在关塔那摩？
If Willett's right, this gets to the heart of habeas. The whole point is that the king shouldn't have the right to just detain somebody because it'd be an embarrassment to have the guy free. The Pentagon has an acronym for people like the Uyghurs, it's pronounced [? "en leck." ?] It means, no longer enemy combatant. But as Willett notes, it should be never was enemy combatant.
如果威利特是对的，这触及了人身保护令的核心。重点是国王不应该有权利仅仅因为把那个人放出来会很尴尬而拘留他。五角大楼对像维吾尔人这样的人有一个缩写，读作“en leck”。意思是“不再是敌方战斗人员”。但正如威利特指出的那样，应该是“从来都不是敌方战斗人员”。
Since I first talked to Willett for our original broadcast, the White House finally found a refugee center in Albania where they sent 5 of the 23 Uyghurs, including Adel. The others are still in Guantanamo and are classified as enemy combatants.
自从我为了我们最初的广播第一次和威利特交谈以来，白宫最终在阿尔巴尼亚找到了一个难民中心，在那里他们送去了23名维吾尔人中的5名，包括阿德尔。其他人仍在关塔那摩，被归类为敌方战斗人员。
The problem with creating an offshore legal limbo, where there's no habeas proceeding to separate the al-Qaeda fighter from the comedy writer, comes during interrogation. If we've labeled them as terrorists, then that's how they get treated. Josh Colangelo-Bryan is a lawyer at Dorsey & Whitney in New York who volunteered at Guantanamo. He represents Juma al-Dossary.
创造一个离岸法律边缘地带的问题在于，那里没有将基地组织战士与喜剧作家分开的人身保护程序，这出现在审讯期间。如果我们把他们标记为恐怖分子，那么这就是他们受到的待遇。乔希·科朗杰洛-布莱恩是纽约多西-惠特尼律师事务所的一名律师，他自愿在关塔那摩工作。他代表朱马·阿尔-多萨里。
For a while, the government thought al-Dossary was a recruiter in America for al-Qaeda. Possibly involved in the case known as the Lackawanna Seven. But this is never brought up at his CSRT hearing. Instead, the government simply states that he's al-Qaeda. And as proof, lists the various places he's been. Afghanistan, Bosnia, Azerbaijan, the Pakistan border. Supposedly he was fighting in some of those places, but the government provides no evidence of that. They don't quote witnesses. Nobody is on record saying he's al-Qaeda. Here's Colangelo-Bryan.
有一段时间，政府认为阿尔-多萨里是基地组织在美国的招募者。可能涉及被称为“拉克万纳七人组”的案件。但这从未在他的CSRT听证会上被提及。相反，政府只是简单地说明他是基地组织成员。作为证据，列出了他去过的各种地方。阿富汗、波斯尼亚、阿塞拜疆、巴基斯坦边境。据说他在其中一些地方战斗过，但政府没有提供证据。他们不引用证人。没有记录显示他是基地组织成员。这是科朗杰洛-布莱恩。
What's interesting to me when we talk about what he was doing in that part of the world is the allegation that the US military makes against him. That he was quote, "present at Tora Bora," close quote. The military offers no allegations as to when Juma was supposedly in Tora Bora. It says nothing about what supposedly he was doing. Simply that at some point in history, he was present in that place.
当我谈到他在世界那个地方所做的事情时，有趣的是美国军方对他的指控。即他所谓的“出现在托拉博拉”。军方没有提出朱马何时在托拉博拉的指控。它什么也没说他应该在做什么。只是在历史上的某个时刻，他出现在那个地方。
Now, Juma says that he's never been to Tora bora. And again, even if that allegation is true, frankly, it doesn't prove anything. Absent some evidence of some involvement in terrorist activity, I simply don't know how you can call someone a terrorist.
现在，朱马说他从未去过托拉博拉。同样，即使那个指控是真的，坦率地说，它也证明不了什么。在没有证据证明参与恐怖活动的情况下，我简直不知道你怎么能称某人为恐怖分子。
We tried out many of our new interrogation techniques on Juma al-Dossary. Colangelo-Bryan met with him many times and cataloged what was done with him.
我们在朱马·阿尔-多萨里身上试用了许多我们的新审讯技术。科朗杰洛-布莱恩多次会见他，并将对他所做的事情进行了编目。
Al-Dossary said that Americans forced him to the ground and urinated on him. We put out our cigarettes on him. We shocked him with an electric device. We spat on him. We poured a hot cup of tea on his head. We told him that quote, "we brought you here to kill you." We beat him until he vomited blood. We threatened to have him raped. We dressed him in shorts and left him in a frigid, air conditioned room. We abandoned him in another room with no water. We invited him to drink from his toilet bowl, which he did. We wrapped him in an Israeli flag. We told him that we would hold him forever, and we told him that we would send him to Egypt to be tortured.
阿尔-多萨里说，美国人把他按在地上并向他撒尿。我们把香烟在他身上掐灭。我们用电击装置电击他。我们向他吐口水。我们把一杯热茶倒在他头上。我们告诉他，“我们把你带到这里是为了杀了你”。我们打他直到他呕吐出鲜血。我们威胁要让人强奸他。我们给他穿上短裤，把他留在冰冷的空调房里。我们把他扔在另一个没有水的房间里。我们邀请他喝马桶里的水，他照做了。我们用以色列国旗裹住他。我们告诉他，我们将永远关押他，我们告诉他，我们将把他送到埃及去受折磨。
On a different day, we chained him to the floor and cut off his clothes while a female MP entered the room. We dripped what we said was menstrual blood on his body. When he spat at us, we smeared this blood on his face. We kissed the cross around our neck and said, "this is a gift from Christ for you Muslims." We videotaped the entire episode.
在另一天，我们把他锁在地板上，并在一名女宪兵进入房间时剪掉了他的衣服。我们在他的身体上滴了一些我们说是经血的东西。当他向我们吐口水时，我们把这种血抹在他的脸上。我们亲吻我们脖子上的十字架，说：“这是基督给你们穆斯林的礼物”。我们录下了整个过程。
There's no way to confirm that all this happened to al-Dossary. But other prisoners, and officials at Guantanamo have described variations of every technique on the list, including the menstrual blood, the Israeli flag, the references to Christianity, the beatings, the sexual humiliation.
没有办法证实所有这些都发生在阿尔-多萨里身上。但其他囚犯和关塔那摩的官员描述了名单上每一种技术的变体，包括经血、以色列国旗、对基督教的引用、殴打、性羞辱。
Al-Dossary's interrogated still, about once a month. During one visit last winter he asked Colangelo-Bryan, what can I do to keep myself from going crazy? A few months later, during a meeting, al-Dossary asked to go to the bathroom. Colangelo-Bryan and the MP stepped outside the hut and waited. After five minutes, colangelo-Bryan got concerned. He cracked the door open.
阿尔-多萨里的审讯仍在继续，大约每月一次。去年冬天的一次访问中，他问科朗杰洛-布莱恩，我能做些什么来防止自己发疯？几个月后，在一次会议期间，阿尔-多萨里要求去洗手间。科朗杰洛-布莱恩和宪兵走到棚子外面等候。五分钟后，科朗杰洛-布莱恩感到担忧。他把门推开了一条缝。
When I opened the door, the first thing I saw was a pool of blood on the floor in front of me. I then looked up and saw a figure hanging. I yelled to the MPs for help. They then began to cut down the noose around Juma's neck.
当我打开门时，我看到的第一件事是面前地板上的一滩血。然后我抬头看到一个人影悬挂着。我向宪兵求助。然后他们开始剪断朱马脖子上的绞索。
It wasn't Al-Dossay's first suicide attempt.
那不是阿尔-多萨里的第一次自杀尝试。
About three weeks later I was back in Guantanamo, Juma said to me that he didn't want to kill himself without an outside witness. His fear was that if he died and only the military knew, nobody would have known what happened.
大约三周后，我回到了关塔那摩，朱马对我说了，他不想在没有外界证人的情况下自杀。他担心的是，如果他死了，只有军方知道，没有人会知道发生了什么。
Of course, as we are often told, this war is different. Who wants to be the one that lets somebody go, who then turns out to be the next 9/11 hijacker. So for the military, there's also this other new thing, a terrifying calculation that there can be no margin of error. Joe Margulies of the University of Chicago represents a few detainees, and has been trying to make sense of what's happened at Guantanamo.
当然，正如我们常被告知的那样，这场战争是不同的。谁想成为那个放走某人，结果发现那个人却是下一个9/11劫机者的人呢？所以对于军方来说，还有这另一件新事物，一种可怕的计算，即不能有误差空间。芝加哥大学的乔·马古利斯代表了几个被拘留者，并一直试图弄明白关塔那摩发生的事情。
If we give them the benefit of the doubt, it is possible-- and there's a lot of evidence to support this. They had no idea who they were going to be capturing. And they thought they might get more serious people. People who were more seriously involved. The reality is those people never came to Guantanamo. The most serious folks are the ones in CIA custody, of which there are approximately 30. 27, 30, something like that. Those are the people in black sites that we don't even know where they are.
如果我们给他们一点怀疑的余地，这是有可能的——而且有很多证据支持这一点。他们根本不知道他们要抓的是谁。他们以为他们可能会抓到更严重的人。更严重参与的人。事实是这些人从未到达关塔那摩。最严重的人是那些在CIA监护下的人，大约有30人。27，30，类似这样的数字。这些人是在我们甚至不知道在哪里的秘密监狱里。
The people of any significance never arrived at Guantanamo, but they didn't know that when the base opened. They said at the time that these were the worst of the worst, they were trained killers, they would gnaw through hydraulic lines to bring down the plane that was flying them to Guantanamo. I mean, they used the most inflammatory rhetoric. And it very quickly became apparent that they were just mistaken. And then they were stuck with this PR nightmare. And at the same time, there was this sense, this nagging sense, that, well, maybe they are really bad, but we just can't find out. Maybe they're not Afghan dirt farmers as all appearances seem to be. How do we really know? Maybe we need to use more aggressive techniques to find out. So they kept turning up the heat and using more and more coercive techniques on people who were less and less significant.
任何重要人物从未到达关塔那摩，但当基地开放时他们并不知道。他们当时说这些人是坏人中的坏人，他们是训练有素的杀手，他们会咬断液压管把送他们去关塔那摩的飞机弄下来。我的意思是，他们使用了最具煽动性的修辞。而且很快就很明显，他们只是弄错了。然后他们就被困在这个公关噩梦中。与此同时，有一种感觉，这种挥之不去的感觉，嗯，也许他们真的很坏，但我们只是找不到证据。也许他们不是阿富汗的泥腿子，正如所有迹象似乎表明的那样。我们怎么能真正知道呢？也许我们需要使用更激进的技术来找出真相。所以他们不断加大力度，对那些重要性越来越低的人使用越来越多的胁迫手段。
Meanwhile, our clients are experiencing this really scary deterioration in their mental health as hope gradually disappears. They have become increasingly desperate, and so that's why there's a hunger strike there going on, an unknown number of people who are starving themselves. Who are being force fed through a tube through their nose that goes into their stomach, and they're only staying alive through that.
同时，我们的当事人正在经历这种非常可怕的心理健康恶化，因为希望逐渐消失。他们变得越来越绝望，这就是为什么那里发生了绝食抗议，数量不明的人正在挨饿。他们被通过插入鼻子的管子强制喂食，管子进入他们的胃，他们只能靠这种方式活着。
In this new war, the plan was to build a prison so bleak that the detainees would give up hope and talk. The military was given a mission and they did a good job. But many prisoners are now moving into year five. If they're al-Qaeda, detainment is perfectly justified. No one argues that. But think about what these incarcerations are for men wrongfully and indefinitely detained. It's like being buried alive in a coffin. Nobody knows how many of the prisoners are, in fact, the worst of the worst, and how many are innocent. But we have a way to find out, it's called habeas corpus.
在这场新战争中，计划是建造一个如此荒凉的监狱，以至于被拘留者会放弃希望并开口说话。军方被赋予了一项任务，他们做得很好。但许多囚犯现在进入了第五个年头。如果他们是基地组织成员，拘留是完全合理的。没有人会争论这一点。但想想这些监禁对被错误和无限期拘留的人意味着什么。就像被活埋在棺材里一样。没有人知道囚犯中有多少人实际上是坏人中的坏人，又有多少人是无辜的。但我们有一种找出真相的方法，它被称为人身保护令。
Jack Hitt. Coming up, the most popular poem among prisoners at Guantanamo. Or if not the most popular, at least it's very, very popular we're told. That is in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
杰克·希特。接下来，关塔那摩囚犯中最受欢迎的诗。或者如果不是最受欢迎，至少是非常、非常受欢迎的，我们被告知。那在一分钟后。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, "Habeas Schmabeas," stories from Guantanamo. We're rebroadcasting a show that we first broadcast one year ago.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目，“人身保护令，去死吧”，来自关塔那摩的故事。我们正在重播我们在一年前首次播出的节目。
So where do things stand now? Well, in the Fall of 2006, this past Fall, the president signed a law with solid bipartisan majorities that officially denies habeas rights to Guantanamo prisoners. At this point, the CSRT is still the closest thing the detainees have to a habeas hearing, and the CSRT rules have not changed. Prisoners don't get to see the evidence that's used against them. And evidence obtained through torture can be used. All of this is on appeal and will probably end up in the Supreme Court.
那么现在情况如何呢？嗯，在2006年秋天，也就是去年秋天，总统在两党多数派的支持下签署了一项法律，正式拒绝了关塔那摩囚犯的人身保护令权利。在这一点上，CSRT仍然是被拘留者所拥有的最接近人身保护令听证会的东西，而CSRT规则没有改变。囚犯看不到用来对付他们的证据。并且通过酷刑获得的证据是可以使用的。所有这些都在上诉中，最终可能会提交到最高法院。
This actually brings us to act two of our show. Act two, "September 11, 1660."
这实际上把我们带到了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，“9月11日，1660年”。
Habeas rights were originally created in England, and in one of the Supreme Court cases on this issue, 175 members of the British parliament filed a, "friend of the court" brief, an amicus brief. The first time in Supreme Court history that this has happened. And they argued first of all, that British citizens being held at Guantanamo deserved better than what they were getting in terms of these rights. And they also said, essentially, are you guys nuts? This is from their brief.
人身保护令权利最初是在英格兰创造的，在关于这个问题的最高法院案件之一中，175名英国议会议员提交了一份“法庭之友”摘要，即“法庭之友”陈述。这是最高法院历史上第一次发生这种情况。他们首先争辩说，被关押在关塔那摩的英国公民在这些权利方面值得比他们所得到的更好的待遇。他们还说，基本上，你们这帮人疯了吗？这是来自他们的摘要。
"The exercise of executive power without possibility of judicial review jeopardizes the keystone of our existence as nations. Namely, the rule of law."
“在没有司法审查可能性的情况下行使行政权力，危及我们作为国家存在的基础。即法治。”
It also pointed out the history of habeas. How after World War II Winston Churchill wanted to suspend habeas rights for Nazi leaders and just shoot them. And it was the United States which argued for habeas and for trials, which led to the Nuremberg Trials. They also finally pointed out how badly it had gone the last time that they, in England, tried to suspend habeas like this.
它还指出了人身保护令的历史。二战后温斯顿·丘吉尔想暂停纳粹领导人的人身保护令权利并直接枪毙他们，这是如何发生的。而正是美国主张人身保护令并主张审判，这导致了纽伦堡审判。他们最后还指出了上一次他们在英格兰尝试像这样暂停人身保护令时情况有多糟糕。
"In the 1600s, they write, during the British Civil War, the British created their own version of Guantanamo Bay and dispatched undesirable prisoners to garrisons off the mainland, beyond the reach of habeas corpus relief."
“在1600年代，他们写道，在英国内战期间，英国人创建了他们自己的关塔那摩湾版本，并派遣不受欢迎的囚犯到离大陆的驻军处，超出了人身保护令救济的范围。”
The guy who did that was named Lord Clarendon. And in England, one of our regular contributors, Jon Ronson, decided to look into it.
做这件事的家伙名叫克拉伦登勋爵。在英格兰，我们的一位常规撰稿人乔恩·罗森决定调查一下。
So it turns out that the last person to come up with this exact same way to sidestep habeas corpus is a lord I have never heard of, a not household name lord called Clarendon. Who was he?
结果发现，最后一个想出这种完全相同的方法来绕过人身保护令的人是一个我从未听说过的勋爵，一个不是家喻户晓的勋爵，叫做克拉伦登。他是谁？
I went to a professional, Tony McDonnell, who said he'd take me to Clarendon's grave in Westminster Abbey.
我去找了一位专业人士，托尼·麦克唐纳，他说他会带我去看克拉伦登在威斯敏斯特教堂的坟墓。
Yes, we're here in the south of Westminster Abbey.
是的，我们现在在威斯敏斯特教堂的南边。
I noticed we just passed Charles Darwin's grave.
我注意到我们刚才经过了查尔斯·达尔文的坟墓。
Yes, Charles Darwin is buried here.
是的，查尔斯·达尔文就葬在这里。
You said you were once showing an American party around and somebody spat it, spat at Charles Darwin's grave.
你说你曾经带着一个美国旅游团，有人朝查尔斯·达尔文的坟墓吐痰。
On his grave, yes. And wanted to know why he was buried here.
在他的坟墓上，是的。并想知道为什么他被埋在这里。
And we just passed the spot where Elton John sang "Candle in the Wind" at Princess diana's funeral.
我们刚经过埃尔顿·约翰在戴安娜王妃葬礼上演唱《风中之烛》的地方。
Yes, that was in front of Lord Stanhope's memorial in the nave.
是的，那是在中殿斯坦霍普勋爵的纪念碑前。
You have to be famous or a great loyalist, or at least someone who worked here, like an organist to be buried here. Tony is a historian and a blue badge guide, an official Westminster tour guide. He took me down corridors and through chambers until we came to a flagstone on the floor, Lord Clarendon's grave. He's in [? vaulted ?] company. Henry the V is buried just to his left, and Elizabeth the I lies a couple of yards in front of him. Tony explains who Lord Clarendon was.
你必须很有名，或者是一个伟大的保皇党，或者至少是一个在这里工作的人，比如管风琴师才能葬在这里。托尼是一位历史学家和蓝色徽章向导，一名官方威斯敏斯特导游。他带着我穿过走廊和房间，直到我们来到地板上的一块石板，克拉伦登勋爵的坟墓。他在很好的公司里。亨利五世就葬在他左边，伊丽莎白一世躺在他前面几码处。托尼解释了克拉伦登勋爵是谁。
He was for want of a better word, nowadays he'd probably be called a prime minister. And he was the main adviser to the king.
他用一个更好的词来说，今天他可能会被称为首相。他是国王的主要顾问。
So Clarendon had this job. He was the king's advisor in the middle of a civil war, in which the king was killed.
所以克拉伦登有这份工作。他是国王在内战中的顾问，在那场战争中国王被杀。
There were two sides. You've got the monarchists and then you've got the puritans who murdered the king because they saw the kingdom as debauched and decadent. Now I know you Americans see puritans as kindly settlers constantly sitting down to Thanksgiving dinner. We see them as bastards. They were religious fundamentalists. In other words, they were--
有两方。你有保皇党，然后你有清教徒，他们谋杀了国王，因为他们认为王国是堕落和颓废的。现在我知道你们美国人把清教徒看作是不断坐下来吃感恩节晚餐的友好定居者。我们认为他们是混蛋。他们是宗教原教旨主义者。换句话说，他们是——
Men who believed that all they had to do was to overthrow the government and the reign of Jesus Christ would come once more among them.
相信他们所要做的就是推翻政府，耶稣基督的统治就会再次降临在他们中间的人。
So this was a bustle of civilization. It was a bustle of religious ideology.
所以这是一个文明的喧嚣。这是一个宗教意识形态的喧嚣。
It was most definitely a bustle of religious ideology.
这绝对是一个宗教意识形态的喧嚣。
So as puritans, were they seen to be kind of crazy, religious fundamentalists, these people?
所以作为清教徒，他们被视为疯子，宗教原教旨主义者吗，这些人？
Some of the people were, and they were among the most persecuted after the Restoration.
有些人是，他们是复辟时期后受迫害最严重的人之一。
The Restoration. This is when the whole sending people away to offshore islands with dubious sovereignty business took place. It was the period after the war. The puritans had been defeated, a king, Charles the II was restored to power, along with his main advisor, Lord Clarendon.
复辟时期。这就是把人送到离岸岛屿上那种可疑主权的企业发生的时候。那是战争后的时期。清教徒被击败了，一位国王，查理二世被恢复了权力，连同他的主要顾问克拉伦登勋爵。
Consider what it was like for Clarendon and the monarchists. They'd been in exile for years. Many of their friends and supporters had been locked up or killed. The puritans had been vicious. They had killed the king. And many of the men who'd done it, were still at large, plotting out there. It was a 9/11 style trauma and Clarendon behaved in a traumatized way.
想想对于克拉伦登和保皇党来说那是什么样的。他们流亡多年。他们的许多朋友和支持者被关押或杀害。清教徒是恶毒的。他们杀死了国王。而且许多做过这件事的人仍然逍遥法外，在外面密谋。那是一种9/11式的创伤，克拉伦登的行为方式受到了创伤。
He probably was paranoid to some extent. The whole of the new establishment were paranoid. They saw plots everywhere. And there was a feeling of retribution in the air. Some people say they had good reason to be paranoid.
他可能在某种程度上是偏执的。整个新政权的人都是偏执的。他们到处都看到阴谋。而且空气中有一种报复的感觉。有些人说他们有充分的理由偏执。
Well, these people had done the most unimaginably horrific acts. They killed the king.
好吧，这些人做出了最不可想象的恐怖行为。他们杀了国王。
They had killed the king and they were capable of anything is what that would have been said. That's why they were put where they were and it was for the safety of all of us, and we're doing you all a favor. Heaven knows what would have happened. They were wicked people and those were the people who were then shipped off by Clarendon.
他们杀了国王，他们有能力做任何事情，这就是会被说的话。这就是为什么他们被放在他们所在的地方，这是为了我们所有人的安全，我们是在帮你们所有人一个忙。天知道会发生什么。他们是邪恶的人，而那些人正是后来被克拉伦登送走的人。
The exact location of Lord Clarendon's Guantanamo is lost to history. It was probably in Jersey or Guernsey, which today are rather nice seaside tax havens for the rich. But suspending habeas corpus didn't work out well for Lord Clarendon. He was impeached.
克拉伦登勋爵的关塔那摩的具体位置已经消失在历史中。它可能在泽西岛或根西岛，那里今天对富人来说是相当不错的海边避税天堂。但暂停人身保护令对克拉伦登勋爵来说并没有什么好下场。他被弹劾了。
At his impeachment trial, he was accused of sending people away to, quote, "remote islands, garrisons, and other places, thereby to prevent them from the benefit of the law, and to produce precedence for the imprisoning of any other of his majesty's subjects in like manner." And remember, democracy as we know it is still centuries away. Innocent until proven guilty, one man one vote, only the most extreme radicals held these views. These were dark times. There were heads on spikes all over London. And still, the people were shocked by Clarendon's disregard for habeas corpus.
在他的弹劾审判中，他被指控将人送往所谓的“偏远岛屿、驻军和其他地方，从而防止他们获得法律利益，并为类似地监禁他陛下的任何其他臣民开创先例”。记住，我们所知的民主仍然还要几个世纪。无罪推定，一人一票，只有最极端的激进分子才持有这些观点。那是黑暗的时代。伦敦到处都是插在长矛上的头颅。即便如此，人们还是对克拉伦登无视人身保护令感到震惊。
People took it seriously and they would have bandied it about with each other, this idea that you had to produce somebody and accuse them in law in front of their own peers. The parallels are so obvious when you read the history of habeas corpus and the amount of times it's just been suspended. That is what they always, always do. They say that these people are capable of anything. These people do not hold the same values as we do. They're out to destroy our way of life. It's more or less the same situation.
人们认真对待它，他们会互相讨论，这种你必须带某人出来并在法律面前在他们自己的同行面前指控他们的想法。当你读到人身保护令的历史以及它被暂停的次数时，这种相似之处太明显了。这就是他们总是、总是做的事情。他们说这些人有能力做任何事情。这些人不持有与我们相同的价值观。他们要破坏我们的生活方式。这或多或少是同样的情况。
The one outcome of all of this was the habeas corpus act of 1679, which specifically forbade what Clarendon had done and made it illegal to send a prison quote, "into Scotland, Ireland, Jersey, Guernsey, Tangier, or into parts, garrisons, islands, or places beyond the seas, which are, or at any time hereafter, shall be within or without the dominions of his majesty." And forbade at his remains for 330 years. In England, anyway.
所有这一切的一个结果是1679年的《人身保护令法》，该法案特别禁止了克拉伦登所做的事情，并规定将囚犯送往“苏格兰、爱尔兰、泽西、根西、丹吉尔，或海外的部分、驻军、岛屿或地方，或者是，或在将来任何时候，将会在他陛下的统治范围内或之外”是非法的。并且禁止了330年。至少在英格兰是这样。
Jon Ronson. He does documentaries for the BBS and is the author of the book, Them.
乔恩·罗森。他为BBS制作纪录片，是《他们》一书的作者。
Act Three, we interrogate the detainees. Yes, the US military had their chance with them. In this act, Jack Hitt talks to two former detainees from Guantanamo. One of these guys you've heard a little bit from earlier in our show, Badr Zaman Badr, the guy who ran the satirical magazine named Pashto with his brother in Pakistan.
第三幕，我们审讯被拘留者。是的，美国军方有机会与他们接触。在这一幕中，杰克·希特与两名来自关塔那摩的前被拘留者交谈。其中一个人你在我们节目的早些时候听到过一点，巴德·扎曼·巴德，那个在巴基斯坦和他兄弟一起经营名为普什图语的讽刺杂志的家伙。
The other guy was 19 when he was picked up, Abdullah Al Noaimi, a kid from a well to do family in Bahrain. Here's Jack.
另一个人被抓时19岁，阿卜杜拉·阿尔·诺艾米，一个来自巴林富裕家庭的孩子。这是杰克。
Abdullah wound up in American custody the way a lot of the men at Guantanamo did, he was a foreigner in Pakistan and we were offering bounties for guys like that. Remember Murat Kurnaz, the guy whose friend was supposedly a suicide bomber and Juma's al-Dossary? Same thing happened to them.
阿卜杜拉进入美国监护的方式和关塔那摩的许多人一样，他是巴基斯坦的一名外国人，而我们正在为那样的家伙提供悬赏。还记得穆拉特·库尔纳兹吗，那个朋友被认为是自杀式炸弹袭击者的家伙，还有朱马·阿尔-多萨里？同样的事情也发生在了他们身上。
In Abdullah's case, he was first taken to Kandahar, to a makeshift prison the US set up at an air base with about 20 men to a tent.
就阿卜杜拉而言，他首先被带到坎大哈，带到了美国在一个空军基地建立的一个临时监狱，帐篷里大约有20人。
When we first go in Kandahar, I was surprised, like I never seen those pictures or those views. Only in the ancient movies, like dark ages. We were chained by the legs, like shackled. And they ordered us to pick up rocks. Can you imagine this? They said, you should pick up the rocks on the ground, like put it all together on a pile.
当我们第一次进入坎大哈时，我很惊讶，就像我从来没见过那些照片或那些景色。只有在古老的电影里，像黑暗时代。我们的腿被锁链锁着，就像戴着脚镣。他们命令我们捡石头。你能想象这个吗？他们说，你应该捡起地上的石头，把它全部堆在一起。
There was no water to make [UNINTELLIGIBLE] or to take a shower.
没有水来洗礼或洗澡。
Badr, the satirist, was taken to that same air base at Kandahar.
讽刺作家巴德被带到了坎大哈的同一个空军基地。
The MPs were treating us very harshly. We had to be on our knees for long hours and to put our hands on our head. And mostly they used the word [BLEEP]. And they used to tell us to put our [BLEEP] hands on our [BLEEP] heads. And we didn't like that.
宪兵对待我们非常严厉。我们不得不长时间跪在地上，把手放在头上。他们大多使用[哔]这个词。他们过去常叫我们把我们的[哔]手放在我们的[哔]头上。我们不喜欢那样。
In the camps, Badr got separated from his brother, the poet. So he devised a way to find him. The detainees didn't have toilets, instead they got a bucket, which got filled up with what Badr modestly calls "dirt."
在营地里，巴德与他的诗人兄弟分开了。所以他设计了一种方法来找到他。被拘留者没有厕所，相反他们得到了一个桶，桶里装满了巴德谦虚地称为“脏东西”的东西。
Every day, some detainee get chosen to empty the buckets. Badr volunteered.
每天，一些被拘留者会被选中去倒桶。巴德自告奋勇。
Because I wanted to meet my brother. To go from tent to tent. Then my brother, when I saw my brother and he was giving me his bucket to empty that was the first springtime. He said, what a spring it is. There are no flowers and instead of the smell of the flowers, we have this dirt smell. I can't translate it. And actually, it's in Pashto. These are really beautiful lines.
因为我想见我兄弟。从一个帐篷走到另一个帐篷。然后我兄弟，当我看到我兄弟时，他把他的桶给我去倒，那是第一个春天。他说，这是什么样的春天啊。没有花，取而代之的是这种脏东西的味道。我翻译不出来。实际上，它是普什图语的。这些是非常美丽的诗句。
The sanitary conditions were just as bad, if not worse, for Abdullah. The tent he shared with other detainees was open on all sides and located at the end of the military airstrip. Every takeoff and landing meant a tornado of dirt-- the literal kind-- blasted through.
卫生条件对于阿卜杜拉来说同样糟糕，甚至更糟。他和被拘留者共用的帐篷四面透风，位于军事简易机场的尽头。每一次起飞和着陆都意味着一场尘土龙卷风——字面意思——席卷而过。
In the first few days, he heard the other prisoners in the tent talking about their interrogations.
在头几天，他听到帐篷里的其他囚犯谈论他们的审讯。
They told me that they had electric shocks on them. And one of them was threatened to be raped. And they took off his pants. And I was thinking, what am I going to do? They took me at night. There was two interrogators. They wanted me to say that I was a terrorist. I told them, no, I'm not and everything. Then they started pushing me and everything. And then they brought a cigarette that the interrogator was smoking. He blew the smoke on my face and then he came very close, very, very close to my face, and brought the cigarette between my eyes. And he said, I swear to God I'm going to put it in your forehead if you don't tell me what I want to hear. I thought about it. I felt like this is a jungle and only the strong lived in it. But still there is small creatures that can live, but not by facing-- the lions aren't facing big animals. No.
他们告诉我，他们受过电击。其中一人被威胁要被强奸。他们脱掉了他的裤子。我在想，我该怎么办？他们在大晚上把我带走。有两个审讯者。他们要我说我是恐怖分子。我告诉他们，不，我不是，等等。然后他们开始推我，等等。然后他们拿来一根审讯者正在抽的香烟。他把烟吹在我的脸上，然后他靠得非常、非常近，把香烟凑到我的眉间。他说，我发誓，如果你不告诉我我想听的话，我要把它插在你的前额里。我想了想。我觉得这就是一个丛林，只有强者才能活下去。但仍然有一些小生物可以活下来，但不是通过面对——狮子不面对大动物。不。
But by maybe hiding or changing their colors as the trees. So I just told them whatever you want to hear from me I'm going to tell you. What do you want me to say? He said, say that you're a terrorist. You want me to say I'm a terrorist? Are you going to let me go? Are you going to let me go sleep? Because they always torture, like not keeping me asleep. They keep me awake all the time. So I tell them, OK. I'm going to tell you whatever you want. Yeah, I'm a terrorist and go tell your bosses. They left me.
而是通过躲藏或者像树一样改变颜色。所以我只是告诉他们，无论你想从我这里听到什么，我都会说。你想让我说什么？他说，说你是恐怖分子。你想要我说我是恐怖分子？你会让我走吗？你会让我去睡觉吗？因为他们总是折磨，像不让我睡觉。他们一直让我保持清醒。所以我告诉他们，好的。我会告诉你无论你想要什么。是的，我是恐怖分子，去告诉你的老板们。他们离开了我。
This is not how he thought things would go with the Americans. In fact, back when he was being held on a Pakistan jail, when he found out that Americans would be taking them, he was relieved. He told the other prisoners it was good news. He knew America, he knew how the people were.
这和他想的与美国人之间发生的事情不一样。事实上，当他被关在巴基斯坦监狱时，当他发现美国人会带走他们时，他感到宽慰。他告诉其他囚犯这是好消息。他认识美国，他知道人们是什么样的。
And I lived so many places, like Europe and England, and Germany, and France. But the difference was in the states, everywhere you go they welcome you. Like when you go in the supermarket, everybody goes, how you doing and everything. That's the thing that was in my mind. I was like, please, everything's going to be fine. They're going to understand.
我在很多地方住过，像欧洲、英格兰、德国和法国。但区别在于，在美国，无论你去哪里，他们都欢迎你。就像当你走进超市时，每个人都说，你好吗之类的。那是存在于我脑海中的东西。我想，求你了，一切都会好起来的。他们会理解的。
So how did he know so much about American supermarkets? Well, in 1994, he came to America for the World Cup finals. In fact, Abdullah's been here a lot. He's been downhill skiing in the Midwest. He attended Old Dominion University in Virginia for a while, and has taken other trips too.
那么他是怎么知道这么多关于美国超市的事情的？嗯，1994年，他为了世界杯决赛来到美国。事实上，阿卜杜拉经常来这里。他在中西部滑过雪。他在弗吉尼亚的老道明大学读过书，也进行过其他旅行。
And in '96 I was in Disneyland in Orlando. For spring break I was in Daytona Beach with some of my friends.
96年我在奥兰多的迪士尼乐园。春假期间我和朋友们在代托纳海滩。
You were in Daytona Beach for spring break?
你在代托纳海滩过春假？
Yeah, it was year 2000. Bikers week.
是的，那是2000年。机车周。
I remember the guys, young guys standing by the sidewalk having the signs for the car for [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Some expressions [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE], show us.
我记得那些家伙，年轻人站在人行道边，手里拿着车牌，展示给我们看。一些表达方式[乱码短语]。
Oh, right. That expression, the show us your--
哦，对。那种表达，向我们展示你的——
Yeah, that expression. That's the most I remember about Daytona.
是的，那种表达。那是关于代托纳我记住的最多的事。
So a year after seeing the sights in Daytona Beach, Abdullah found himself facing an American interrogator in Kandahar.
所以，在看代托纳海滩的风景一年后，阿卜杜拉发现自己正在坎大哈面对一名美国审讯者。
I got shocked. I got shocked when the first interview, like cursing me up and down. Cursing my father, cursing my family. Cursing my country. Cursing my government, everything. Why? That was the question I wanted to know. What's going on? Do I know you? What do you have against me? What did I do to you?
我受到了冲击。在第一次面试时，我受到了冲击，比如咒骂我上下。咒骂我父亲，咒骂我的家人。咒骂我的国家。咒骂我的政府，一切。为什么？那是我想知道的问题。发生了什么事？我认识你吗？你对我有什么不满？我对你做了什么？
Badr had learned of the West from more scholarly sources. He's a big fan of the Canterbury Tales and Gulliver's Travels. And he also knew about the Geneva Conventions and spoke up when he realized they weren't going to apply.
巴德从更学术的来源了解了西方。他是《坎特伯雷故事集》和《格列佛游记》的忠实粉丝。他也知道《日内瓦公约》，并在意识到它们不适用时提出了抗议。
Actually, our complaint was that they were not accepting us as prisoner of war. They were not giving us those rights. And actually, they were just running from American legal system. I mean, I had told my interrogators many times, if we are really guilty, why don't they put us on trial in American courts?
实际上，我们的抱怨是他们没有承认我们是战俘。他们没有给我们这些权利。事实上，他们只是在逃避美国法律体系。我的意思是，我多次告诉我的审讯者，如果我们真的有罪，为什么不把我们放在美国法庭上受审？
Finally, Badr and Abdullah were each taken out of the camps at Kandahar and put on a plane to Guantanamo. Remember, this is an international flight from Afghanistan to Cuba, over 20 hours long.
最后，巴德和阿卜杜拉分别被带离坎大哈的营地，被送上了一架去关塔那摩的飞机。记住，这是一次从阿富汗到古巴的国际航班，飞行时间超过20小时。
We were handcuffed and the handcuffs was tied to our stomachs. And there is a chain connected to our legs. Other detainees next to you are stuck to you.
我们戴着手铐，手铐被系在我们的肚子上。有一条链子连接到我们的腿上。你旁边的其他被拘留者被粘在你身上。
They used to put [UNINTELLIGIBLE] on our head.
他们过去常把[乱码]放在我们的头上。
And we had masks that we can hardly breath.
我们戴着呼吸困难的面具。
We could not hear, we could not see. We can even not touch. So they had to stop all senses completely.
我们听不见，看不见。甚至不能碰。所以他们必须完全停止所有感官。
To have hearing, seeing, tasting, smelling, those things only human can have.
拥有听觉、视觉、味觉、嗅觉，那些东西只有人类才能拥有。
Once they got to Guantanamo, both Badr and Abdullah described being stripped naked, medically examined, and then put into cages until a new round of interrogations began.
一旦他们到达关塔那摩，巴德和阿卜杜拉都描述了被剥光衣服、医学检查，然后被关进笼子里，直到新一轮审讯开始。
Mostly they used to ask questions about the various organizations and how they get money why people hurt Americans and so and so. And there have been even stupid questions.
他们大多过去常问关于各种组织的问题，以及他们如何获得资金，为什么人们伤害美国人等等。甚至还有愚蠢的问题。
Like?
比如？
There have been stupid questions, that if we have seen Osama bin Laden, [UNINTELLIGIBLE], if we intend to attack Americans.
有愚蠢的问题，比如我们是否见过奥萨马·本·拉登，[乱码]，我们是否打算攻击美国人。
As if I know Osama bin Laden. I was shocked, I'm 19 years old.
好像我认识奥萨马·本·拉登一样。我很震惊，我才19岁。
Abdullah and Badr, by the way, arrived at different times at the base, and never knew each other. But they both described meeting lots of ordinary people, farmers, teachers, cab drivers, who were also sold to the Americans. Abdullah talked to one guy who sold by his own father-in-law. Badr met men who had never even heard of Osama bin Laden.
顺便说一句，阿卜杜拉和巴德在基地到达的时间不同，从来没见过面。但他们都描述了见到许多普通人，农民、老师、出租车司机，他们也被卖给了美国人。阿卜杜拉和一个人交谈，那个人被他自己的岳父出卖了。巴德见过的男人甚至从来没听说过奥萨马·本·拉登。
Abdullah was originally arrested while traveling in Pakistan. A man offered him a meal, and a place to rest, and later turned him over to the army for the bounty. Abdullah says he saw the money change hands at the jail. Once in American custody, he was accused of traveling to Afghanistan and proclaiming his desire to carry out Jihad.
阿卜杜拉最初是在前往巴基斯坦旅行时被捕的。一个男人给他提供了一顿饭和一个休息的地方，后来为了悬赏把他交给了军队。阿卜杜拉说他看到钱在监狱里易手。一旦进入美国监护下，他被指控前往阿富汗并宣称自己渴望进行圣战。
Sometimes the interrogators want to put the stress on us. They come and ask me, do you want to go home? They don't want to take me home, but they're just asking. To make you angry and nervous that you'll never go home and keep telling you those things. but in response, I tell them the same thing. No in fact, I don't want to go to home. I'm OK here. I like you so much and I don't want to leave you.
有时审讯者想给我们施加压力。他们过来问我，你想回家吗？他们不想带我回家，但他们只是在问。让你愤怒和紧张，让你再也回不了家，一直对你说那些事。但作为回应，我告诉他们同样的事。不，事实上，我不想回家。我在这里挺好的。我非常喜欢你们，不想离开你们。
Now did they think you were a smartass? How did they react to that?
现在他们有没有认为你是个聪明人？他们对那个有什么反应？
They got surprised the first time, but then they got used to it because everybody say it. Even if, for example. stop you from food, stop you from sleeping, stop you from talking. I don't know why, you just keep smiling.
他们第一次感到惊讶，但后来他们习惯了，因为每个人都这么说。即使，例如，停止你的食物，停止你的睡眠，停止你的谈话。我不知道为什么，你只是不停地微笑。
So much of what we hear about Guantanamo is about the harsh treatment there. But of course, like any place, the days mostly pass in boredom. The interrogators might be rough, but the MPs and guards who had to spend time with the detainees sometimes would get comfortable and start talking to the prisoners.
我们听到的关于关塔那摩的大部分内容都是关于那里的严酷待遇。但当然，像任何地方一样，日子大多在无聊中度过。审讯者可能是粗暴的，但必须与被拘留者共度时间的宪兵和警卫有时会变得自在，并开始与囚犯交谈。
They ask me, tell me the truth. Are you a terrorist or not? They were told that I'm a terrorist, but they still ask me. Why? Because of doubt in their hearts. They still have doubt. They don't seem like as we've heard. And then we start talking and talking and talking. Most of the guards they told me that when I first came here I was trained that everybody over here is like monsters. They're going to jump from the cages and they're going to chew you up and everything. They said, we thought different. We thought that the American forces captured you in a battle or something. So some people they are forced to treat us bad. But you can see, you can tell from their eyes. And some they feel like this is not the right thing to do. They feel this is wrong. They told me themself. Some of them told me, if I don't follow orders, I'm going to be in your place. I really miss them now.
他们问我，告诉我实话。你是恐怖分子吗？他们被告知我是恐怖分子，但他们仍然问我。为什么？因为他们心中的怀疑。他们仍然有怀疑。他们看起来不像我们听到的那样。然后我们开始谈话谈话谈话。大多数警卫告诉我，当我第一次来到这里时，我被训练成每个人在这里都像怪物一样。他们会从笼子里跳出来，把你嚼碎等等。他们说，我们想得不一样。我们以为美国军队是在一场战斗中抓住了你们。所以有些人他们被迫坏待我们。但你可以看到，你可以从他们的眼睛里看出。有些人觉得这样做是不对的。他们觉得这是错的。他们自己告诉我的。他们中的一些人告诉我，如果我不服从命令，我就会待在你的位置上。我现在真的很想念他们。
To pass the time, the prisoners would sing together, or try out new poems they'd written. They developed a secret postal system for passing notes and photos, and figured out how to talk to each other through the air conditioning vents. Sometimes, the guards and prisoners would hold little competitions, like the styrofoam cup challenge. The object was to turn the cup inside out without cracking it. The guards went first.
为了打发时间，囚犯们会一起唱歌，或者尝试他们写的新诗。他们开发了一个秘密邮政系统来传递纸条和照片，并想出了如何通过空调通风口互相交谈。有时，警卫和囚犯会举行小比赛，比如泡沫塑料杯挑战。目标是在不弄裂它的情况下把杯子翻过来。警卫先试。
They spent hours and hours and hours and they came back. They couldn't do it. They said, OK, let's try it to flip the cup underwater. They tried and it didn't work. Then the detainees said, OK, we're going to do it for you. The detainees did it. They flipped the cup inside out. Like totally inside out. You could read the brand of the cup inside the cup instead of outside.
他们花了几个小时几个小时几个小时，然后他们回来了。他们做不到。他们说，好吧，让我们试着在水下翻转杯子。他们试过了，没用。然后被拘留者说，好的，我们要为你做。被拘留者做到了。他们把杯子彻底翻转了过来。就像完全翻转过来一样。你可以在杯子里面读到杯子的品牌，而不是外面。
What was the brand?
品牌是什么？
It Dart.
那是达特。
Dart.
达特。
Yeah, one was Dart and the other was Oklahoma. Yeah, community of Oklahoma for blinds.
是的，一个是达特，另一个是俄克拉荷马。是的，俄克拉荷马盲人社区。
Since pen and paper were forbidden, Badr's brother wrote his poetry by scratching the words into styrofoam cups with his fingernails. After a year, they were allowed to use pens and to read books. Abdullah read David Copperfield. Badr and his brother composed some 25,000 lines of verse. The other inmates memorized the best of them. The most popular couplet went like this.
因为纸和笔被禁止，巴德的兄弟用手指甲把诗句划在泡沫塑料杯上写下来。一年后，他们被允许使用笔和阅读书籍。阿卜杜拉读了《大卫·科波菲尔》。巴德和他的兄弟创作了大约25000行诗句。其他囚犯背诵了其中最好的。最受欢迎的对联是这样的。
It says, [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE] These are the first two lines. It means, they bring good and bad people to the same jail and there is no oil and salt in the rice.
它说，[说外语] 这是前两行。它的意思是，他们把好人和坏人带到同一个监狱，米饭里没有油和盐。
Get that? There's no oil or salt in the rice.
听懂了吗？米饭里没有油或盐。
It's really funny in Pashto if you just [UNINTELLIGIBLE] to any Pashto speaker in your country, he would really love that. [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE]
如果你把它[乱码]给你们国家的任何普什图语使用者，在普什图语里真的很有趣，他会真的喜欢那个。[说外语]
Finally, one day, four years after he left Pakistan, Abdullah was pulled aside by a military officer who had news. Abdullah was going home. Abdullah says he was asked by a government lawyer, a major, to sign a contract promising not to join a terrorist group and giving the US permission to rearrest him at any time. He refused to sign. Other detainees say they were shown similar letters and also refused to sign, believing this was just another trick.
最后，有一天，在他离开巴基斯坦四年后，阿卜杜拉被一名有消息的军官叫到一边。阿卜杜拉要回家了。阿卜杜拉说，他被政府律师，一名少校，要求签署一份合同，承诺不加入恐怖组织，并允许美国在任何时候重新逮捕他。他拒绝签署。其他被拘留者说他们也收到了类似的信件，也拒绝签署，认为这只是另一个诡计。
Did they ever explain why they were letting you go?
他们有没有解释为什么让你走？
No.
没有。
But they told you they had made a mistake in the end?
但他们最后有没有告诉你他们犯了错误？
The government lawyer, he didn't say a mistake by the lack of vocabulary of mistake. He didn't say mistake. But he said we picked you up as enemy combatant, but it turned out that you are not one. We don't see that you're an enemy combatant. He just give me an example of a mistake, but he didn't say we made a mistake.
政府律师，他没有说错误，因为缺乏错误的词汇。他没说错误。但他确实说我们把你当作敌方战斗人员抓走，但事实证明你不是一个。我们看不出你是敌方战斗人员。他只是给了我一个错误的例子，但他没说我们犯了错误。
And just as suddenly, Abdullah was on an airplane and back in Bahrain. He was quickly ushered past the news media and into a room where he saw his family.
就这样，阿卜杜拉突然上了一架飞机，回到了巴林。他很快被带过新闻媒体，走进了一个房间，在那里他见到了他的家人。
They greeted me. They welcomed me. They hugged me and everything. Then they took me home. I didn't tell them anything. Everybody's crying. I left my sister and she was very young, about five, six years. I didn't know her when I saw her. She was like a lady.
他们迎接我。他们欢迎我。他们拥抱我之类的。然后他们带我回家。我什么都没告诉他们。每个人都在哭。我离开我妹妹时她还很小，大约五、六岁。当我见到她时我都不认识她了。她就像一位女士。
When you saw your brothers and your father, what was that like?
当你见到你兄弟和你父亲时，那是什么感觉？
Have you ever heard the expression, "home sweet home?"
你听说过那句表达吗，“家是甜蜜的家”？
Yes, I have, actually.
是的，我听说过，实际上。
Yeah, of course. That's the best time to say home sweet home.
是的，当然。那是说“家是甜蜜的家”的最佳时机。
Americans are going to think that because you were at Guantanamo Bay that you were a terrorist. And that everybody there was. What would you say to them?
美国人会认为因为你在关塔那摩湾，所以你是个恐怖分子。每个人都在那里。你会对他们说什么？
I would say even if I were an angel, I would still be a terrorist to them because it's the thing that they want. People don't want to take the responsibilities of their mistakes. They want to put it on others. It's like slaughtering a sheep, for example. And when the sheep keeps shaking, and the blood's spilling all over the place, they would scream at the sheep and say, you are a bad sheep. Bad, bad sheep because your blood came on my clothes or my [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. You know what I'm saying? They would take you, maybe torture you, or maybe kill you, or put you under so much stress and circumstance and then they would say, you're a bad person because you've been through those things. Why did you put me in those things in the first place?
我会说即使我是个天使，对他们来说我仍然是个恐怖分子，因为这是他们想要的东西。人们不想承担他们错误的责任。他们想把错误推给别人。就像屠宰一只羊，例如。当羊不停地发抖，血洒得到处都是时，他们会对羊大喊大叫，说，你是一只坏羊。坏，坏羊，因为你的血洒在我的衣服上或我的[乱码]。你知道我在说什么吗？他们会抓你，可能会折磨你，或者可能会杀了你，或者让你承受很大的压力和环境，然后他们会说，你是个坏人，因为你经历了那些事情。为什么你首先让我经历那些事情？
In the years Abdullah was gone, his parents moved to new house, a big house, with lots of rooms. But there was no bedroom for him. His old clothes were gone. They thought he would never come home. He says it's like he's come back from the dead.
阿卜杜拉离开的几年里，他的父母搬到了新房子，大房子，有很多房间。但没有他的卧室。他旧的衣服都没了。他们以为他永远不会回家。他说这就像他从死里复活了一样。
Jack Hitt. In the year since we first broadcast this show, Abdullah's gotten married. He has a six month old son. He's entered business school in Bahrain.
杰克·希特。在我们首次播出这个节目以来的一年里，阿卜杜拉已经结婚了。他有一个六个月大的儿子。他在巴林读商学院。
The other detainee that Jack talked to, Badr Zaman Badr is back in Pakistan. He and his brother wrote a book in Pashto about what happened to them in detention in Kandahar and Guantanamo. Because of this, Badr's brother has been detained by the Pakistan government.
杰克交谈的另一名被拘留者巴德·扎曼·巴德回到了巴基斯坦。他和他的兄弟用普什图语写了一本书，关于他们在坎大哈和关塔那摩拘留期间发生的事情。因此，巴德的兄弟被巴基斯坦政府拘留了。
In this past year, about 200 detainees have been released. About 385 are still in Guantanamo. 38 of them are currently classified as NLEC, No Longer Enemy Combatants. That is, they've been found to be completely innocent, but they're still in custody.
在过去的一年里，大约有200名被拘留者被释放。大约385人仍在关塔那摩。其中38人目前被归类为NLEC，不再是敌方战斗人员。也就是说，他们被发现完全无辜，但仍被关押。
In September 2006, after criticism that not many truly dangerous prisoners were at Guantanamo, 14 high-value al-Qaeda prisoners were moved to Guantanamo from CIA black sites. And finally, just this week, the Justice Department filed petitions in federal court to try to curtail how often detainees can talk to their American lawyers, guys like Joe Margulies and the other attorneys that you heard this hour. An affidavit by a Navy lawyer, commander Patrick McCarthy, complained among other things, that those lawyers were providing information to the news media about the detainees.
2006年9月，在关塔那摩没有太多真正危险的囚犯的批评之后，14名高价值的基地组织囚犯从中央情报局的黑监狱被转移到关塔那摩。最后，就在本周，司法部向联邦法院提交了请愿书，试图限制被拘留者与他们的美国律师交谈的次数，像乔·马古利斯和你们这小时听到的其他律师那样的人。海军律师帕特里克·麦卡锡指挥官的一份宣誓书抱怨说，除其他事项外，那些律师正在向新闻媒体提供有关被拘留者的信息。
Well, our program was produced today by Sarah Koenig and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Jane Feltes, Amy O'Leary and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Sam Hallgren, Seth Lind, Thea Chaloner, Tommy Andreas. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
好了，我们的节目今天由萨拉·凯尼格和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、戴安娜·库克、简·费尔特斯、艾米·奥利里和丽莎·波拉克参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自萨姆·霍尔格伦、赛斯·林德、西娅·查洛纳、汤米·安德烈亚斯。音乐协助来自杰西卡·霍珀。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金来源]
This American Life is attributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia. You know what he always says about us.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台署名。WBEZ管理层对我们节目的监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责。你知道他总是怎么评价我们的。
If anybody actually met these guys, they'd be shocked.
如果有人真的见了这些人，他们会感到震惊。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。